all right so yesterday was day one of
the democratic national convention
i did a live stream of the entire thing
i was commenting i was reading viewer
comments as it was all going on
and um i i don't know
how else to start other than to say it
really wasn't very good now i'll talk
about what expectations
are and how it compares to expectations
and to what
we would expect from trump and i'm going
to contextualize it but there's no way
that i could
come to you today and say i'm so inspire
inspired and invigorated and energized
by what we saw
yesterday um i sent some
early tweets like during the first half
hour
which were really quite negative i said
first off quote
i could have done without the prayer to
jesus to kick off the dnc
not sure about anybody else and i get
that everybody does it and joe biden's
catholic and there's still a pretense
about
religion in the democratic party and
it's not just necessarily a pretense
there are religious people as well and
that that's fine
um they do the pledge of allegiance like
it all just smelled
at this point like republican light
which maybe is the goal and arguably is
still a big part of the
the centrist elements of the democratic
party so i'm not acting surprised by
that i'm just saying
it didn't really resonate with me then
sort of about 20
22 minutes in in fact i said someone
please talk me off the ledge i want to
win and the first 22 minutes of this dnc
i'm scared can someone tell me how great
this is or something
but you know then it did start to
improve and maybe my view was skewed by
the fact that i just hate cliche
packaged politics and that's exactly
what the dnc
the democratic national convention is
designed to be it's designed
to be a package culminating with the
nomination
of in this case joe biden in 2016 26
2012 different people
to get to the election and it's a
package and especially
when you've got coronavirus so it's not
just
the idea of packaging up a candidate and
a platform
but it is quite literally a video
package that has been pre-produced
in combination with live segments you
have no crowd
energy it might be just as bad with the
republican national convention and this
may be just what it is
but it felt very low energy and you know
they'd have an actual
okay speech and then they'd cut
to music or some other kind of interlude
that didn't make sense and took energy
away
but i want to try to really see this as
not
my reaction you know maybe this is the
right thing
like they don't need to convince me i'm
already voting for joe biden
and i actually don't even understand
being undecided at this point
and so maybe this is about a very sort
of
polished inoffensive package
meant to appeal to the few people that
might actually be unsure about who to
vote for like
i don't know is the point but given the
opportunity for democrats to do
something
knowing republicans will also have an
opportunity to do the same thing next
week
i'd rather have the better convention
than the worst one no matter how much it
really matters
in the end now it did keep improving
during the first two hours during the
two hours of the first day
i thought the best parts of the evening
were a woman named
kristen urkisa whose father died of
coronavirus
after voting for donald trump she spoke
really well
and authentically and a lot of the stuff
felt inauthentic
she was really good and then from the
big names
listen bernie was excellent bernie is
always just so clear and precise
with his message and the stakes and i
like that bernie
spoke specifically to his supporters
from both 2016 and 2020 and talked about
the importance
of voting for joe biden this time around
because of the existential threat that
is donald trump let's look at like a
minute of that
my friends i say to you to everyone who
supported
other candidates in the primary and to
those who may have voted for donald
trump
in the last election the future of our
democracy
is at stake the future of our economy
is at stake the future of our planet
is at stake we must come together
defeat donald trump and elect joe biden
and kamala harris as our next president
and vice president my friends
the price of failure is just too great
to imagine thank you
so really nice job by bernie sanders
beautiful aesthetics by the way also if
you were watching
uh bernie came to us from burlington
vermont with a nice wood pile in the
background i mean just very very
uh aesthetically pleasing as well i'm
half kidding i mean it was cool i don't
actually care about that but
seeing the wood pile was nice and then
michelle michelle obama was
was really very good she closed off the
night
i thought maybe she went a bit too long
which i was fine with
but i could see from people in the chat
that some were starting to sort of tune
out a little bit but
i thought she was excellent fantastic
speaker and again check out this clip
from michelle obama
going into this idea of does my vote
even matter
michelle obama making the case very
strongly that yes it does
i've said before being president doesn't
change who you are
it reveals who you are
well a presidential election
can reveal who we are to and four years
ago too many people chose to believe
that their votes didn't matter
maybe they were fed up maybe they
thought the outcome wouldn't be close
maybe the barriers felt too steep
whatever the reason
in the end those choices sent
someone to the oval office who lost the
national popular vote
by nearly 3 million votes
in one of the states that determined the
outcome
the winning margin averaged out to just
two votes per precinct two votes
she took that head on really really well
so
i think maybe what i needed was like an
attitudinal adjustment
you know how should we be thinking about
this does it matter
as i've said before i don't need
conventions this year
i don't need debates this year but if we
are having them
i would rather joe biden have the better
convent convention rather
than the worst one and we'll see how
that continues tonight now donald trump
next week is planning to do his at the
white house
it'll have apparently more of a live
feel than the very pre-produced feel
that the dnc had at least on day one my
guess is trump is going to put together
some kind of in-person crowd that would
be my my guess
now with coronavirus you've got to be
safe you can't do a big thing
packing an arena with 20 000 people
would be crazy
my idea for the speeches
for bernie and michelle and biden etc
for those speeches
i would have instead of doing like 30
short segments as they did yesterday
i would have given the keynote people a
little more time
but made it higher energy by putting
together some small
safe mask wearing socially distant
crowds
outdoors i'm not saying bring i'm not
saying do anything
unsafe but i think we could have gotten
more energy without
increasing the risk of coronavirus with
some small outdoor crowds bernie's crowd
in burlington that's fine
uh michelle's in dc or where you know
wherever they're living or at this point
uh showing the importance of mask
wearing
showing the importance of space but it
would have brought a little something a
je ne sais quoi
that was definitely missing yesterday
that would have been my preference
nothing unsafe
uh we will see how night two goes and i
will be streaming starting about 15
minutes before
the start of day two tonight on youtube
twitch and facebook and i hope that you
will join me there